Eric Knoll you're in London you witness
this stuff happening how surprised are
you by the kinds of allegations that
prosecutors are making against this loan
gentlemen this this
I won't call him a rogue because it
wasn't working for anybody he was
working for himself oh well thank you
Eric for the opportunity to be with you
today
what I would say about it is is I think
there was always a suspicion that there
were bad actors during the flash crash
so as far back as 2010 I think the CFTC
indicated that they were examining some
of the trading because some of the
quoting behavior that people saw there
the allegations against this individual
I think come to a surprise to many of us
in the industry because he was
essentially a lone wolf someone that no
one had dealt with before or understood
before so finding out about it now is is
quite interesting five years after the
fact what does it say about the
integrity of the US equity market that
this guy who's now 36 and clearly was a
few years younger on in May of 2010 when
the flash crash took place that somebody
acting alone without apparently much
sophisticated much of a sophisticated
background in trading for any of the
well-known firms could cause this kind
of disruption raises questions about who
else might be doing it today well I
think those are legitimate questions
like how would someone like this able to
do these things in the markets but I do
want to make a couple of points around
that one is is that this was not the
equity markets even though the equity
markets experienced the flash crash this
was an incident that occurred in the
futures market which then ended up
driving equity prices but also the
industry learned a lot coming out of the
flash crash and put a lot of safeguards
into place to prevent just these kinds
of behaviors so new market wide circuit
breakers limit up limit down on
individual securities pre trade market
access rules for market participants to
prevent rogue algorithms from entering
the market so a lot of a lot of lessons
that were learned coming out of the
flash crash crash have been put into
place now as we go forward
Terry explain to us exactly what he did
so he did what's called spoofing which
became illegal when dodd-frank was
passed
and President Obama signed it in 2010
where essentially you flood the market
with the ton of orders on any given
security with the intent to cancel those
and in doing that it artificially drives
the price of that security either up or
down
now regulators and criminal prosecutors
consider this a form of market
manipulation and this is the only the
second criminal case with spoofing
charges that we've had since dodd-frank
was passed last year we had Michael
Casca who was indicted on six booths
spoofing charges in Chicago and now we
have this case but I think going back to
your original question Eric one of the
interesting things is why directly
answering my but why did it take them
five years to figure this out and the
guy kept trading up until a year ago
doing all the same stuff so those are
the questions that the regulators and
the stock exchanges and the futures
exchanges are going to have to answer
it's how did all this volume keep
flowing through even after they put all
those safeguards in after the fire Eric
what do you think about that well I
think again I'm not sure in the specific
instances of this trader I haven't read
the indictment and I and they're
obviously serious charges and I look
forward to you know hearing more about
them but I think some of the issues
again that the industry is trying to
resolve for itself are I mean the stock
exchanges and the SEC are putting to
play something on the consolidated audit
trail which will provide all of the data
of all the trading back to the
regulators so that they'll have more of
a real-time view and picture of what's
happening in the marketplace but I think
there are some legitimate questions to
answer here as to like how did this
single person have this access to the
marketplace and why did it take that
long to find well but as far as the
taking that long to find it on the one
hand we want to give if not credit right
prosecutors the the leeway they need to
be able to build a bulletproof case
absolutely on the other hand even before
it becomes a criminal case how does the
the market you know the the sort of the
operations that oversee the market what
room did they have to step in and stop
these kinds of things happening and I
think that's where you have the
lay in action happening so we have a
market structure issue with the
regulators and how they're responding
and then criminal prosecutors then have
to go through and incredibly technical
you're a very high bar to very high bar
to get a case like this cleared you know
to indictment so how you know and they
work completely separately obviously
prosecutors cannot regulate the market
and they cannot be responsible for
market structure Eric should to see it
should thus eme itself have some kind
I'm not familiar enough for the
structure of the futures market I know a
little bit more about the structure of
the equity market but based on what you
know is there a self-regulatory or
policing role for an organization like
the CMA to play here well the CME and
the National Futures Association take
responsibility of self-regulatory
organizations for the future side of the
business so again I don't have enough
facts here to make a judgement or to
know what they were doing or examining
this or really whether whether this
gentleman's activity rises to the level
of criminal activity remember that he's
doesn't it's a confidence issue and
we've been wrestling this ever since the
flash crash and for that matter before
ever since the meltdown in US equity
markets in the wake of the financial
crisis investors look at the trading
volumes they're coming back but it's
taking years people are still afraid and
when they when they open up
bloomberg.com or when they happen to
open up the newspaper or listen to our
conversation here they ask themselves if
this guy if this guy can mess with the
equity market to this degree and was
allowed to continue trading until I
think it was April of last year what
business do I have in the market well I
again going back to some of the changes
and lessons that we've learned is that
it's a very complex market and we know
that and and it's electronically linked
to one another and there's fragmentation
and there are lots of concerns that
we're trying very hard to address as an
industry however I think real reform has
taken place real changes have taken
place but to your earlier point about
people being scared away from the
equities market of course since the
financial crisis of 2008-2009 equities
have had very very nice returns and so
that if you have avoided a lot of people
haven't enjoyed because they were afraid
to trade
you know so this so they've they've
missed out on that because I do think if
you look at the history of what's
happened here the equity markets
actually worked very well there are
changes there are reforms there are
necessary things that we have to
consider and continue doing and some
have already been taken but I do think
that the markets generally work very
very well for price discovery and
liquidity